I hate to tell you this.
You did not get it correct.
>> But let- >> So what did I do wrong?
>> Yeah, let me tell you.
So, when you're looking at the, at the new example,
you have to figure what parts of it to be paying attention to.
We call these features.
So a feature might be the color.
It might be- >> Like, white.
>> How many legs it has.
>> Four.
>> It might be whether it has horns or antlers.
>> Oh.
So a horse does not have horns or antlers.
>> You're right. >> But these all have horns and antlers and that's what-
>> I see. >> Acerous means,
is that it's lacking horns or antlers, antennae, things like that.
So that's why a horse would be a, an, an example of an acerous animal.
>> Okay.
>> And this is, in general, what machine learning is going to be doing is we
give you a bunch of examples and each one has a number of features,
a number of attributes that you can use to describe it.
And if you can pick out the right feature and
it's giving you the right information then you can,
you can classify new examples.
So a smart machine algorithm would have outperformed me?
>> I think so yeah.
>> Darn so let's,
don't take this class because I don't want all you guys to outperform me.
>> Well no I wouldn't go that far.
I think the way to think about it is what's the way that we
could use machine learning algorithm to get problems like this right and
that's the whole point of this lesson.
>> Okay